je vais me marier je te déteste pas
alors bien mon mariage
oui j'aimerais bien que la vie c'est
très très simple il n'y va pas un point
c'est tout vu les siens séparables
tutour susan vous souhaitez vraiment
tout pour être heureux tout sous mais
bon j'étais ya longtemps voici donc tort
il a fallu que tu mords pas donc à temps
et l'ex d'alison c'était corps que c'est
vraiment tout juste avant aaron hill et
et aaron est si parfait et salut hors
jeu trouve ça super cool que tu sauves
mais c'est vraiment énorme
on est tous les deux énormes moi j'ai
vraiment un tout petit pays sans
observer mon nom c'est pas le cas non
une bonne vanne à qui la cuisine est ce
que cette direct accompagnés au mariage
de changer que parfait
j'aimerais apprendre cette famille à
trappes jean marc petit ami est en train
se marier avec ce petit ça c'est moche
je parle maintenant ou qu'il se taise à
jamais oui j'ai quelque chose à dire
[Musique]